let's bring it back to to Dante because  everybody everybody's been asked in the  comments everybody wants to know how  many fans you [ __ ] damn everybody and  I think you guys all like you guys all  artists there's a dog here there's a dog  here somebody brought a dog in here oh  my God is this dog Dante was about to  give us something how many girls did you  [ __ ] that day  no fans out dude I really honestly think  there is a relationship that we have the  fan base you should violate that  relationship well what the [ __ ] is Joe  been doing his whole life it's not a  violation it's the highest year of  patreon you don't think people want to  [ __ ] have sex with this guy and be  like hey when you bust can you please  Crow  how's that ever happened uh let's focus  on more wholesome things yeah yeah you  were recently in Hawaii being a pastor  complete 180 dude